[Musique]
bonjour la semaine dernière georgge
Marchet a consacré avec ses camarades et
avec ses amis qui soutiennent sa
candidature toutes ces émissions à vous
exposer ce que peut-être une grande
politique française nouvelle une
politique de plein emploi de lutte
contre toutes les injustice de blocage
de la hausse des prix et surtout il a
mis en lumière les moyens nécessaires
pour réaliser une telle politique
l'ensemble de ces objectifs vous les
trouvez dans les 131 propositions dont
George Marchet vous a donné connaissance
en même temps le candidat communiste a
répondu à toutes les questions posées
par les syndicats par les organisations
professionnelles de paysans de
travailleurs indépendants par les
associations les plus diverses de
personnes âgées d'handicapées d'invalées
tant d'autres encore il a répondu à tous
tous connaîent ses positions il s'est
adressé à la jeunesse dans une émission
spéciale à la radio et hier soir il a
parlé aux originaires des départements
et territoires d'outremer ce qui lui a
valu deux lettres l'une de guidanin
secrétaire du Parti communiste de la
Guadeloupe l'autre de Paul vergess
Réunion qui l'assure de son comp de leur
complet soutien aujourd'hui Georg
Marchet veut traiter d'une très grande
question pour la France pour les
français pour les Françaises il a invité
pour cela Giselle Morau Giselle Morau
est employée elle est aujourd'hui député
et elle occupe les fonctions les plus
importante au Parti communiste français
Giselle Morau bien pour nous l'élection
présidentielle se situe dans la suite de
notre action quotidiennes pour les
revendications des femmes et pour le
changement nous sommes dans les
entreprises avec les travailleuses pour
défendre leurs droits l'emploi leurs
conditions de travail leur salaire leur
dignité nous sommes dans les cités
populaires avec les femmes pour lutter
contre les saisies les expulsions les
hausses de loyers pour réclamer
l'augmentation des allocations
familiales bien cela des millions de
femmes le voient le savent et nous
luttons aussi contre les mentalités
rétrogrades et pour l'égalité de la
femme pas par des parlotes mais par des
actes mais Giselle Bau il ne suffit pas
d'être une femme pour bien défendre la
cause des femmes éidment évidemment et
les femmes en font chaque jour
l'expérience avec Madame Peltier sa
politique c'est et celle de Monsieur
giscardestin c'est l'aggravation des
inégalités le chômage la vie chè et les
difficultés en particulier pour les
femmes seules mais nous ne séparons pas
le combat des femmes du combat des
travailleurs c'est pourquoi nous disons
changer la vie des femmes et bien c'est
porter atteinte à la loi du profit
briser cette loi de l'argent et George
Marchet le seul candidat à vouloir le
faire à l'occasion d'une campagne
électorale George Marchet non non mais
en vous écoutant tout à l'heure je
pensais que s'il suffisait d'être une
femme pour résoudre les problèmes des
travailleuses et des ménagères il suffit
de regarder ce qui se passe du côté de
l'ondde avec Madame tachcher cela étant
dit pour répondre plus précisément à ta
question non il ne s'agit pas pour moi
d'une question nouvelle qui aurait surgi
avec la campagne électorale il y a 10
ans c'était dans une réunion qui s'était
tenue à l'Olympia à Paris je crois
j'avais mis en évidence le fait que
selon moi euh l'événement l'un des
événements sans doute les plus
importants des dernières décennies
c'était la participation massive des
femmes aux luttes économique social et
politique euh d'ailleurs devant cet
événement évidemment les patrons tombent
desnus comment les femmes les femmes
dans la lutte et bien je leur ai dit
d'ailleurs durant toute la campagne
électorale messieurs les patrons vous
n'avez rien vu les femmes soumises
craintifes passives c'est fini c'est
bien fini vous ne reverrez jamais plus c
ch dans toutes les grandes entreprises
mais aussi dans les petites et les
moyennes qu'il ne faut pas confondre
avec les artisans non il ne faut pas
confondre effectivement avec les
artisans tu as tout à fait raison cela
étant dit les petites et moyennes
entreprises ont doublé leur profit
depuis que Giscard destin est au pouvoir
et c'est dans ces entreprises-là que les
travailleurs et en particulier les
travailleuses les femmes sont les plus
exploité j'ai rencontré des femmes qui
aujourd'hui encore subissent les
abattements de zones qui sont interdits
de depuis
1968 c'est la raison pour laquelle il
faut soutenir elles sont d'autant plus
exploitées ces femmes il y a pas de
syndicat il y a pas de parti dans ces en
somme pour que ça change Giselle c'est
bien vrai il faut que les femmes
s'enmêlent absolument ce qui nous amène
à faire le point de la campagne
électorale nous voici à 4 jour du
premier tour georgge marché toi depuis
le début tu montres ton jeu les cartes
sont sur la table mais naturellement en
fin de campagne il se développe des
manœuvres diverses ce sont des sondages
des déclarations des affiches c'est fait
pour brouiller les
cartes d'abord je dirais que je trouve
tout cela excessif et bien loin des
préoccupations des Français et des
Français chômage tu as dit toi-même tout
à l'heure
inflation problème de l'école du
logement et cetera et cetera nous sommes
loin avec ces manœuvres effectivement
des problèmes qui préoccupe les gens tu
as tout à fait raison oui mais dans
cette campagne bien sûr l'objectif des
autres il est toujours Mme depuis le
début il est de réduire l'influence du
candidat communiste parce que le
candidat communiste il est porteur de
l'espoir c'est lui qui peut ouvrir la
porte à l'Union et au changement s'il a
la force suffisante évidemment c'est la
raison pour laquelle Giscard desestin
voit de plus en plus rouge toujours
antigiscar gege marché toujours
antigiscar pour la raison bien simple
c'est que dans mon
combat les objectifs que je poursuis
c'est le défi du plein emploi que je
lance à Giscard tin c'est le défi d'une
politique de justice sociale c'est le
défi d'une France indépendante luttant
pour la paix et le désarmement dans le
monde et tout cela c'est le défi de
l'égalité des femmes mais ce sont tous
ces défis qui leur font peur alors ils
ne soivent plus quoi inventer pour
embrouiller les choses et détourner les
Français les électrices et les électeurs
d'un vote libre au premier tour alors on
voit Chirac Chirac qui se présente déjà
comme s'il était àélisé ça ne m'étonne
pas avec lui il exagère toujours on voit
François mitteran dire que au premier
tour les électrices et les électeurs
n'auraient pas le droit de choisir le
candidat de leur choix librement au
moment même où nous apprenons par un
journal du soir que une négociation est
en cours entre François mitteran et
giscardestin pour organiser entre eux un
débat entre les deux tours tout cela
sont vraiment des manœuvres ce sont des
manœuvres dont l'objectif est bien clair
c'est d'essayer de diminuer au maximum
l'IMP importance des voix qu'aura le
candidat communiste oui ils font
d'autant plus d'effort d'ailleurs pour
cela que moi je le sens je renontre
beaucoup de gens je fais beaucoup de
réunions en particulier avec des femmes
et bien on peut dire que le courant
grandit en faveur du candidat communiste
il y a une volonté d'union et de
changement extrêmement forte dans le
pays c'est parce que George Marchet a
ouvert la porte il a ouvert l'issue dans
son émission de carte sur table le 23
mars je crois que tu as été entendu j'ai
été entendu je le sens dans les réunions
auxquelles je participe le que je reçois
les appels qui sont très nombreux à
voter pour moi mais malheureusement il
me faut faire une constatation j'ai été
entendu de beaucoup de Français mais je
n'ai pas été entendu par François
mitran la semaine dernière je parla avec
un ami qui reflète assez bien le
l'opinion ce que pensent les gens et il
me disaient il me disait ceci avec
François mitteran c'est flou on ne on ne
sait pas où on va alors euh le refuse de
s'engager clairement oui c'est le refuse
de s'engager clairement alors moi je
pense que au contraire ce dont besoin ce
dont ont besoin les Françaises et les
Français c'est la chose suivante il y a
la crise est-elle fatale non elle n'est
pas fatale on peut en sortir alors il
faut une politique claire il faut des
objectifs précis correspondant aux
intérêts des travailleurs manuels et
intellectuels et de la paysannerie
objectif mais moyen évidemment pour
atteindre pour réaliser ses objectifs
c'est la deuxème question et 3oè
question avec qui mettre en œuvre une
telle politique les Françaises et les
Français le savent je répète partout où
je passe aucun parti je dis bien aucun
parti ne peut prétendre dans ce pays
gouverner seul il faut nécessairement
une alliance j'ai proposé clairement
pour ma part si je suis élu je
constituerai immédiatement un
gouvernement socialiste communiste
capable de mettre en œuvre la politique
nouvelle mais François mitan ben
François mitteran continue d'affirmer
d'une part le alors d'un côté c'est le
flou je l'ai dit et dans les objectifs
et dans les moyens et d'autre pas le mot
de profit non le mot profit est un mot
tabou et d'autre part c'est le refus des
ministres communistes et François
mitteran dit d'ailleurs lui aussi
affaiblir le Parti communiste c'est
nécessaire pour pourquoi parce qu'il
veut se garder les mains libres
réfléchissons un peu ensemble il veut se
garder les mains
libres parce que il veut éventuellement
gouverner avec la droite il faut battre
gisc et il faut créer les conditions
pour écarter le danger d'un accord d'une
alliance comme tu disais entre le Parti
socialiste et la droite les Françaises
et les Français le savent bien ce ne
sont pas des inventions de notre part ça
s'est déjà vu dans le passé en France ça
se voit à l'extérieur nos frontières
dans d'autres pays et partout où ça
s'est fait où ça se fait les
travailleuses et les travailleurs
connaissent des déboirs par conséquent
devant le patronat la droite qui se
prépare à une telle coalition socialiste
et droite il est indispensable de
dresser une barrière de prendre une
assurance en somme de barrer la route à
ce danger pour ce qui me concerne j'en
suis plus convaincu que jamais on peut
battre GIS on peut
gagner on peut changer mais évidemment
cela dépend du vote du 26 avril au
premier tour cela dépend des Françaises
et des Français j'ai expliqué clairement
quels étaient mes objectifs les moyens
de les atteindre à la fois au plan
économique et politique ce qu'il faut
c'est me donner la force qui est
nécessaire pour avancer dans cette voie
c'est ça le vote utile pour les
travailleuses et les travailleurs oui et
cela pourrait bien être les femmes qui
feront pencher la balance du bon côté
les travailleuses et les travailleurs en
ont vu d'autres dans ce pays nous savons
bien que la lutte pour l'Union elle
connaît des hauts et des bas il y a des
moments difficiles et l'expérience
montre une chose ce n'est pas la
première fois que que le Parti
socialiste refuse nos propositions mais
pour parvenir à réaliser l'union il faut
que le poids si je puis dire dans la
balance pèse du bon côté c'est-à-dire du
côté de l'Union d'où l'importance du
vote du premier tour d'où mon appel de
ce matin dans un article que j'ai publié
tout est encore possible voilà mon avis
donc on peut gagner on peut gagner il
faut rassembler le maximum de voix sur
le nom du candidat communiste sur George
Marchet sur le maximum de voix de femmes
et d'hommees notre prochaine émission
aura lieu avec René andréeux qui
interviewera George Marchet René Andreux
et rédacteur en chef de
l'humanité